NARRATOR: Researchers
have confirmed
100 bull shark attacks.
But the real number may be much
higher because the bull shark
is so difficult to identify.
When you first
look at a bull shark,
it doesn't really jump out at
you that it's a bull shark.
It just kind of looks
like other sharks.
You have kind of grayish
brown on top, white below.
That's really different from an
iconic species like the tiger
shark that has that
really square head
and those stripes that set it
apart from any other species.
And then you also
have white sharks.
Nobody's going to
mistake a white shark.
This is a really iconic look.
You have the torpedo shape, the
tail, the bright white belly,
slate gray above.
NARRATOR: The bull shark's
looks aren't showy or iconic.
But if you know what to look
for, you'll never forget it.
When you really start to
look closer at the bull sharks,
you see some
features that differ
from typical shark shape.
They almost look like
swimming mounds in time.
They're really thick from
those pectoral fins forward,
huge jaws.
And then, they've got the
musculature to back that up.